what's going on guys the summer movie
season coming to a close before the
summer started we assembled an esteemed
panel of some of the finest movie Minds
to make their predictions on the top ten
summer box office films domestically the
results are in are you as excited as I
am to find out who won let's say hello
to our returning panelists first she is
one of the co-hosts of the podcast
tights and fights the wrestling podcast
yes and one of the role players on the
live Twitter ole playing show valiant
Vanquish
welcome back Daniel Radford good to see
you again yes and oh you know I'm you
love me as a head writer of honest
trailers an all-around swell guy Spencer
Gilbert yeah and oh this man is you know
them from movie fights and honest
trailers and all over the place thanks
for coming across the hall Mr Dan
Morelle yes so what do we think about
the summer what are just some overall
impressions right out the gate
well that was that's the it's a weird
paradox which is that box-office wise
the summer was a pretty big
disappointment as far as numbers go
mm-hmm I think the movies were way
better than last summer which was a
better box-office years what's one of
your big surprises that you're like man
why did that do so bad or that
overperformed in my eyes it was exactly
as bad as I thought it was going to be
but transformers the last night when you
look at how much that made not just in
here in the US but globally like
transformers age of extinction was a 1
billion dollar movie with a be three
years later it's making half that it was
by far the lowest grossing here in the
US but to see it takes such a dive
globally simultaneously that's not how
it usually works so I thought cheers
fours last night was going to I said I
did they could do well here but I
thought it would do a billion dollars
overseas that was my biggest surprise is
that like not only did we lose interest
in transformers the world lost interest
in transform ah making the world a
better place right after all
yes Spencer did you have any
films that are like wow I did not expect
that war for the plan of the age deserve
better
this was a beautiful end to one of the
better movie trilogies in recent history
yeah and it kind of left with a thud
box-office wise and quality wise this
was up there with the first two I don't
understand why people skipped it the way
they did but the movie probably deserved
a better shot absolutely
it opened between spider-man and Dunkirk
which nobody saw except for you the
box-office phenomenon that Dunkirk was
gonna be not phenomenon but that it
would do that well and now as we are
historically and one of the worst
august's of Hollywood ever hindsight
being 20/20 I think were complaining so
I'd have done better if that was coming
out of it this weekend Danielle you were
the highest on Wonder Woman which one
the entire summer you had at number
three on your list now we're able to see
the future or you just chalk it up to
girl power how did you know that Wonder
Woman is gonna do so I hedged it simply
because at the time there were a lot of
there were rumors people were saying
different things some people were saying
that it was looking like it was going to
be good some people had felt really
soured on the DC franchise by that point
my thing was if it is a good movie it's
going to do well because Wonder Woman is
a huge iconic character and this was the
first time that she's had a huge movie
and she is one of the big three she's
like one of the most recognizable names
in superheroes and so I knew when I
argued at the time that if Wonder Woman
wound up being good and it's this huge
marquee film women were gonna come out
and we did and well we came out a lot
and it wasn't just us everybody saw that
movie one well-trod franchise that still
made the top 5 Pirates dead men tell no
tales I mean Johnny Depp still sailed
that ship to box-office gold kind of I
mean it's in a relative term this was
again by far the lowest grossing Pirates
film domestically internationally it did
well it's in a seven to eight hundred
million dollar range did not make a
billion dollars like the last one so
even pirates I think is now showing
signs of lagging off you know pirates
and Bay
both open the same weekend I think they
might have cannibalize each other's box
office too but I think particularly with
pirates it was why do I need to go see
this movie and now I think that was the
word of mouth and people that saw it was
like it's a pirates movie it's exactly
the same as the other pirates movies and
it's getting harder hard to get people
off the couch and I just don't think
that movie offered anything new to
motivate people to go see it I do think
it's a good point about it come at the
same time as Baywatch just because they
were both you think pirates obviously
you think action but you also think very
broad comedy Baywatch was clearly all
broad comedy with like some action so
there is a chance that if like if you're
gonna see one wacky thing that weekend
you were gonna pick between the two of
those movies yeah there's a little bit
of been-there-done-that fatigue in
regards to that film and I speaking of a
little bit of fatigue man the rock
didn't bring it this year dan and
Danielle you both had Baywatch on your
list and with good reason
Central Intelligence top-10 film last
year the year before San Andreas was a
top ten so a box office grossing film
what happened the third year running I'm
sitting in this chair bemoaning of rock
it's never you're never gonna catch up
to the rock he's always gonna surprise
you chase the rock you just hold your
hand at the rock San Andreas didn't pick
central intelligence did pick Baywatch
Baywatch didn't work cuz maybe because
the rock wasn't in it he was gone for
like the first the last almost third act
of the movie like for a movie that was
featuring the rock they sure didn't
feature the rock that much you just
spoiled Baywatch for me Dan how dare you
the script spoiled Baywatch for you
let's take a look at some of the
outliers some of the over performers and
under performers on our lists Danielle
you had seven right out of ten the three
that did not make it
Baywatch as we mentioned the mummy and
The Dark Tower what the mummy it was
another one that was gonna start a
franchise I thought more people would be
curious about it if nothing else
yeah and just know no one cared I
figured at least like maybe that first
weekend people would say you know the
universal starting a new thing we're
gonna come out at least
be curious enough to check it out you
know it's got the Tom Cruise he's great
at running but no no and then with dark
tower I guess I thought that more people
who read the books and we're huge fans
of Stephen King we're gonna come out
regardless and even a lot of those
people were like yeah no no thanks like
this isn't what I signed up for it
wasn't what I wanted I think that a lot
of the marketing didn't really do it a
lot of good people were going in
expecting I think it to be more of like
a 1:1 translation of the book which it
turned out that it was not oh so those
all those things combined that knocked
me yes you you had the top three films
of the summer different order but you're
on point there yeah nicely done Dan
so you hit 8 out of 10 and it was just
your 9 and 10 movies that you thought
would ikan Baywatch and valerian and a
city of a thousand you got to take a
risk and I took a role on valerian which
take yourself back to me looked very
intriguing very interesting I knew that
it was risky it was obviously a bad bad
choice however I will say I would not
have picked either of the two movies
that replace mine which are Dunkirk
which I think far exceeded a lot of
people's expectations the girls trip we
have been that's the wildlife for this
summer that's the movie that nobody
picked that no it wasn't even anyone's
radar yeah hilarious movie by the way
it's great to see an actually good funny
movie can bring through I want to give
some shout out isn't a great fan to the
baby driver which is the 11th highest
ranking movies never just eked out of
the top 10 I love that Edgar Wright got
some mainstream success with that movie
and I hope that it even further puts
into people's minds how great of a
director he is and the Hollywood will
give him more chances because he's now
showing he can make something
financially viable
now here's in the running for Pirate six
oh God so you mentioned Dunkirk we
haven't talked a ton about it that's a
little bit of an outlier to me because
it's more of a prestige movie an Oscar
caliber film that made the top ten yeah
well I put in my top ten it yes if you
talk about movies on the Internet
long
if you realized that this guy Chris
Nolan's got some fans he's got some
people who who are who appreciate
something there yes yeah yeah and I was
just banking on the fact that they might
show up and he made the event movie that
you need to see on the big spur yes
that's the big thing about Dunkirk is
that that is a movie that you really
need to see in a movie theater with all
of its glory immerse yourself yeah that
is the kind of movie that that is and I
think it was very wisely sold that way
as well that was like know like don't
wait for this for Netflix you need to
see this seek a 70 millimeter screen
which probably costs more to take a
price I'm gonna jump over to my list
real quick so I at 8:00 right but I also
included Captain Underpants and rough
night and it was a rough box-office
performance for rough night which came
in at 31 Captain Underpants not bad at
16 but that's know top ten finish it
seems so weird that a lot of people were
putting rough night and girls trip kind
of like I know they're very similar
ladies getting a little crazy kind of on
that bridesmaids family tree and the
trailer for girls trip undersold that
movie yeah we really did and that was I
think where a lot of those comparisons
came down because the two of them are
like Oh whack EW
sex workers booty holes yeah I love that
we're seeing the praises of girls trip
because yeah the trailer did look a
little lowest-common-denominator
but then no it was legit funny the movie
had a heart and Tiffany Haddish maybe
the breakout performance of the summer
yes 100% she should get it the same way
that most of Karthika an Oscar
nomination for bridesmaids I think
Tiffany Haddish should get a nomination
for girl strip because I thought her
performance was just as good and just as
much of a breakout okay drum roll please
hope you're banging on your laptop at
home the winner of our box office
predictions with 9 right Spencer Gilbert
would you do it what Dark Gods old or
new did you vote them all but I got to
tell you if Dunkirk was my bet for
Humanity and they they pulled through
emoji poopy was my bet against humans
yes so thank you for not giving a 10
10:4 not going up to support the emoji
movie I thought that movie looked like
poop and I stopped it yeah I'm glad so
yeah Spencer I salute you sir for your
victory and it continues our proud
tradition of never having a repeat
winner we also put out a call to action
for you to give us your top 10 summer
box office predictions and you did and
please without further ado check out our
winner congratulations you got some
prizes coming your way let's all shed a
little tear for the departure of the
summer movie season okay oh that was
really sweet you guys and look forward
to the Oscar baby ball movies yeah
Daniel Radford Spencer Gilbert Dan
Morelle
thank you for coming in and going over
these results and talking movies always
a good time
and I want to thank you for watching
what were your biggest surprises of the
summer let us know in the comments
section below we want to know I want to
thank you for watching I'm how redneck
hit me up on Twitter bye bye
[Music]